to Iquitos the first one I should be
thanks for the introduction and thanks
to the organizers for putting together a
great workshop so today I'm going to
talk about path detection and why it
makes a good quantum algorithm primitive
and this is based on a series of work
with Stacey Jeffery Michael Jaret Alvaro
Pete rafita Quaeda Lorenzo and teal
Witter so when I talk about a quantum
algorithmic primitive what do I mean a
quantum algorithm ik primitive is just
an algorithm but it should be kind of a
tool or a building block that can be
used to design other algorithms so it
should be widely applicable and ideally
it can kind of be used in a block
blackbox manner you just have a black
box that accomplishes some algorithmic
tax tasks and you can easily understand
the behavior of that box without having
to kind of open it up and deal with the
innards of what's going on so kind of a
prototypical example I think of a
quantum algorithmic primitive is
Grover's search it's widely applicable
there are many algorithms that use
search and it's very easy to
characterize how it's going to behave
without having to you know worry about
exactly how the algorithm works you just
know that if you're searching a list of
n things that'll take classically about
time and but quantumly you get a square
root speed-up okay so why is it
important to think about algorithmic
primitives well I think one one reason
it's important is to make quantum
algorithm design more accessible you
know as we're starting to build better
and better quantum computers more and
more people are interested in thinking
about how problems that they're
interested in can can use quantum
computers for an advantage so a lot of
people are asking that question but I
would say not a lot of people actually
want to learn about quantum mechanics
they just want to kind of understand how
they can use the plug in this tool but
if we can provide quantum algorithm make
primitives to the community outside of
quantum computing that they can just use
these tools as black boxes and as long
as their problem has the input that kind
of is allowed or is required by the
black box
they can get a sense for how a quantum
computer could potentially speed up
their problem of interest and I think it
would be a really good thing to have a
wider community of people working on
understanding what quantum computers can
do and how they might speed up different
computations but I think it's also
important even for expert algorithm
designers to think about kind of
compartmentalizing what quantum
algorithms can do I mean we heard in
Richard Koons talk earlier this week
that he had thought about designing his
algorithm so that there was a bottleneck
which then he could use kind of a
quantum algorithmic building block or
primitive to solve that one kind of
tough part of the algorithm and so I
think that's we're having a more mature
field we don't need to design every
quantum algorithm from scratch we can
start to use the tools that we've
developed and think about how to combine
them in interesting ways so what I'm
gonna do today is hopefully convince you
that good quantum algorithmic primitive
is this problem st connectivity so I'll
try to convince you that it's widely
applicable and it's kind of easy to use
in a black box manner without having to
look on the inside and deal with all the
quantumness so for the rest of the talk
I will introduce this problem to you
I'll tell you about SD connectivity and
then I'll talk about why it's widely
applicable and I'll talk about why it's
easy to analyze but just as a preview in
terms of how widely applicable this is
as a quantum primitive or subroutine I
tried to make a list of all of the
problems where people have used this as
a subroutine in solving another
algorithmic problem so you can see for a
lot of these this using ST connectivity
as a subroutine gives you an optimal
algorithm actually continues on to the
next page I'll just mention that this
very last okay obviously you can use an
SD connectivity algorithm to solve SD
connectivity which is the final thing
here but I'll just mention that that
that this algorithm that my card
envelopes first analyzed is the same one
that I'm going to be using today but
with slightly more sophisticated
analyses than what they originally did
but hopefully at least you're slashing
these problems gives you a sense that
this is a problem this is a tool that
can be used in a lot of different
contexts
okay so what is SD connectivity it's
very simple you have a graph with two
nodes s and T and you want to know are
they connected so in this case the
answer would be yes and in this case the
answer is no okay but what's really
important whenever we're talking about
trying to understand what a quantum
computer can do or really what any
algorithm can do is we need to think
about what the input is because if the
problem that we're trying to solve
doesn't have the correct input then we
can't use the algorithm that assumes you
have a certain input okay so the input
to this s/t connectivity algorithm is a
bit string so bits that can take values
0 and 1 and then also what I call a
skeleton graph so the skeleton graph
tells you where edges might be in the
graph so we already know for example
that there's no edge between these two
vertices so ahead of time you know that
some edges might be missing then for the
edges that might be present each one is
labeled by one of the names of the bits
in the input string and/or by its
negation so then once we know the
assignment of the bits of the input
string that allows us to assign edges to
the skeleton graph so if there's an edge
labeled by 3 and X 3 has value 1 then we
put an edge at that position in the
graph or here we also have an edge
that's labeled by the negation of 3 so
then when X 3 is president like if X 3
equals 1 we don't put an edge so every
bit string now corresponds to a graph
and so if the input bit string were 1 0
1 in this case we'd return yes because s
and T are connected if the input string
was 0 0 1 now we remove all the edges
that correspond to 1 and we have a graph
that's no longer connected so we would
output no ok so that's how the this is
the input to the problem and we assume
that this bit string is initially hidden
and we can ask questions to learn what
the values of the bit string so we could
say ok what's the value of x 2 and then
if we learned that it was 1 then
immediately we would we would know that
the graph was connected so that's kind
of the classical version of the input
quantum mechanically were
assume were given an Oracle that allows
us to ask the same question so we can
ask what's the value of bit.i and it
returns that information in a quantum
scanner basis state but it also allows
us to ask this question in superposition
for all of the elements of the input
string okay so basically from here on
I'm just going to assume we have a black
box algorithm that solves this problem
which I mean I guess I don't have to
assume we do have an algorithm that
given this input solves the problem of
whether s and T are connected and so I'm
just going to be treating this like an
algorithmic primitive I'm not going to
be opening up the box I'm just going to
be saying now that we have this
primitive what types of problems can we
solve with it and then once we know that
we can use this to solve a problem how
well does the quantum algorithm behave
and we'll see that it does quite well
kind of in a large range of problems
okay so the next thing we'll talk about
is how so it seems like this problem SD
conductivity obviously it's good at
figuring out whether two points are
connected but how dit can use it to
solve other types of problems that you
might be interested in so I'll talk
about why it's widely applicable so
we'll start with an example of cycle
detection and I'm using this example
because this is something that I've
studied but it also is representative of
how it can be used as a primitive okay
so with cycle detection we want to know
is there a cycle so here there's a cycle
in the graph so we'd return yes there's
no cycle so we should return no and the
input to this problem is given to us
basically in the same way that the SD
connectivity input is given to us so
we're actually given a bit string which
tells us whether edges are present or
not okay so we want to figure out how to
use SD connectivity to solve this
problem so we can break up this bigger
problem of asking whether there's a
cycle to asking a slightly more specific
question asking whether there's a cycle
that goes through edge one well two
things need to occur if there's a cycle
through edge one there needs to be an
edge like edge one needs to be present
but then also there needs to be a path
from one endpoint of edge one over to
the other side that doesn't go through
the edge itself okay but now we can
translate those two criterion into an SD
connectivity problem so here's the SD
connectivity problem that corresponds to
satisfying those two things so there are
two we can kind of think about this as
two sub graphs
there's a sub graph at the top which is
just a single edge which answers that
question is edge one present and then
the bottom sub graph is the original
graph but with edge one removed it asks
if there's a path that goes from one
side of edge one to the other and when
because we want to kind of take the end
of these two credit of these two things
we can connect the graph in series so
we're only going to get all the way from
the top all the way to the bottom if
both of these things hold
now if we want to ask the question is
there a cycle at all well that's there's
gonna be a cycle if there's a cycle
through h1 or h2 or h3 or h4 and so when
we want to take the or of a bunch of
problems and put that into an SD
connectivity kind of approach we can
attach graphs in parallel because now if
there's a path through any one of a
series of graphs in parallel the whole
you're going to have a connection
so here the there's kind of a sub graph
on the Left which is asking whether
whether there's a path a cycle through
h1 and whether there's a cycle through
edge 2 and so on so hopefully I mean
this is not too challenging with a
construction hopefully it's clear that
there's going to be a cycle in our
original graph if and only if there's a
path in our we've converted that problem
into an ST connectivity problem and so
now that I've done this hopefully it
also makes sense why one of the key
applications is to evaluating boolean
formulas so boolean formulas are just
evaluating the and Edoras of a series of
input bits and so if you have I've just
said that oh well if you want to
characterize and you can attach things
in series and if you want to
characterize or you can attach things in
parallel so if we just have a bunch of
ands and ORS that amounts to creating a
graph that's a bunch of edges connected
in series in parallel so this graph on
the right exactly will have kind of SNT
connected in the graph if and only if
the boolean formula evaluates to true at
left so there's a one-to-one
correspondence between
s.d connectivity and boolean formulas
okay so I encourage you to take your
your favorite problem and see how to
convert it into an ST connectivity
problem it's kind of a fun thing to do
but of course so I for many many
problems you can do this conversion but
then the question is would you actually
want to do this how well is the quantum
algorithm going to do on evaluating
these problems like is this a good thing
to do or maybe you should have a more
direct approach that doesn't do this
espe connectivity conversion so let's
talk about the analysis of the quantum
algorithm
but again we're gonna treat it just like
as a black box and just try to
understand its characteristics rather
than getting into the actual functioning
of the algorithm okay so first of all
the space complexity so the quantum
algorithm only uses logarithmic in the
number of edges in the skeleton graph so
that's good whenever you have something
that scale is logarithmic leave that
means it's not going to take use a lot
of cubits just to solve this problem so
given that building large quantum
computers is challenging this is a good
thing so the next thing we're going to
talk about is the query complexity so
career complexity because we're given
this bit string that's initially hidden
the career complexity is the number of
uses of the oracle that i needed to
determine whether s and t are connected
or not with high probability on the
worst case input and so classically that
kind of corresponds to how many
questions do we need to ask of the bit
string before we can answer whether
we're connected or not so create
complexity is a tool that's really nice
to use because it allows us to compare
very easily to the classical version of
these problems and it's also much easier
to analyze the time complexity but often
what we really care about is the time
complexity how long is it actually going
to take to run and so let's say what
we've shown is that the the time
complexity is just a multiplicative fact
is the query complexity times some
multiplicative factor and that factor
depends on the number of operations
needed to implement a quantum discreet
walk on the skeleton graph and it also
depends on a factor that goes like the
spectral graph spectral gap of the
laplacian of the skeleton graph so you
know those things might or might not be
challenging to implement but at least if
you know the query complexity it gives
you some kind of a sense along with a
couple of other factors of what the time
complexity is and if you really care you
could try and figure out what those
terms are and that would immediately
give you the time complexity
okay but we're gonna for the rest of the
talk we're going to focus on query
complexity so the number of times that
you need to use the Oracle to figure out
whether s and T are connected or not the
number of times you need to query the
bit string basically
okay thanks okay
so what is the crea complexity
okay so what is the Korea complexity of
this algorithm it is skills like the
product of two terms the square root of
the maximum effective resistance of any
connected graph times the maximum
effective capacitance of any not
connected graph so what's really nice
about this is that effective capacitance
and effective resistance are terms that
many people are familiar with lots of
physicists who have taken electricity
magnetism and they don't they don't
necessarily it's not like you're having
to analyze or understand a lot of
complicated quantum things these are
basic graph properties that are not so
hard to deal with and I'll get into a
little bit what they are more of what
they are shortly but I'll just mention
that the effective resistance part of
this formula was found by bell of sin
right cart in their original paper and
that the dependence on the effect of
capacitance is work that I did with some
of my collaborators okay so since we're
gonna will shortly look at an example
and we're gonna try to figure out what
the query complexity is and so we need
to understand how to calculate the
effective resistance and the effective
capacitance of our graph of interest so
the effective resistance deals with
graphs where we have a path from s to T
so to calculate the effective resistance
we can imagine having you can imagine
that all of the edges are pipes and we
can have water flowing in at s and
flowing out at t and then a flow is any
kind of we can assign numbers to each
edge and we want to have one unit coming
in at s one unit coming out at t and
then the net flow at any other vertex
being zero so for this example we have
to have kind of one on that upper left
edge but then we can get a split into F
and one minus F so any any value of F
would give us a net zero flow across
that split but then given a flow we can
calculate what we call the flow energy
so that's you just take the floor on
each Edge squared over all edges and
then the effective resistance is just
the smallest energy of any valid flow so
this is a slightly different definition
that way you
if you've like the standard circuit
model definition but it's electrical
circuit definition but it's exactly
equivalent so the value of F that will
give us the smallest effective
resistance is when we said F to be 1/2
when it kind of splits perfectly and
that's how electrons would flow in a
circuit if you had two wines with equal
resistance on them that's the effective
resistance so we would calculate this
for every possible graph where s and T
are connected and whichever graph had
the largest effective resistance that's
the term that would go on that left
quantity the term on the right we look
at all graphs that are not connected so
for every graph that's not connected we
can create a generalized cut so for this
we assign values to every vertex we
assign the value 1 to s and 0 to T and
then we can assign other whatever
there's an edge in the graph we have to
not change the value of the vertices
across that edge but here we have a
vertex that's kind of free that's not
touching other vertices there's no edge
between it so we're allowed to set it
freely to be any real number that we can
define the energy of this cut as we take
the difference across every edge in the
skeleton graph square it and sum that up
over all the edges and then the
effective capacitance is the smallest
potential energy of any of these
generalized cuts so in this case it
would the thing that would minimize this
cut energy and give us the best of
effective classes at students is if we
set that value to be 2/3 at that free
variable and this is again exactly kind
of analogous to what you would get if
you were looking at the effective
capacitance of a circuit where the cuts
are kind of the capacitance or the
numbers they are giving you the voltage
at each part of the circuit
okay so now that we have those tools we
and we know the query complexity we can
analyze how well our quantum algorithm
is going to do on a problem of interest
so let's go back to this cycle example
that we had earlier so here's now our ST
connectivity problem and so we want to
know what is the worst effective
resistance and what is the worst
effective capacitance so let's think
about the case that there's a cycle with
three edges well that means there's
going to be a path through every one of
those sub graphs corresponding to each
one of the edges and each one of those
paths is going to be of length three so
more generally if we have a K length
cycle we're gonna have K parallel paths
of length K and because if we're
thinking about the flow for the
effective resistance that's gonna give
us a 1 over K flow on each one of those
paths that's gonna be the best we can do
and so then when we square that and sum
up over that all of the edges we find
that the worst-case effective resistance
is always 1 for a single and if there's
multiple cycles that actually just
lowers the effective resistance further
because there's more paths that the flow
can take and less flow going on each
path and so when you square it it ends
up being even better so we have a bound
on the effective resistance the next
thing is to calculate the worst-case
effective capacitance so in this case
the effective capacitance is always less
than the size of the smallest cut and so
in this case it doesn't actually buy us
that much to worry about the details of
the effective capacity of like we can
just assign numbers 1 and 0 and not
worry about assigning these intermediate
values like 2/3 like we saw in the
previous example and then that just
gives us a standard cut and so in this
case we kind of have two types of sub
graphs we have graphs where we have an
edge being present or we have an edge
not being present so like in this
example 2 3 4 don't have edges present
so we can make a cut right up at the top
and there are order N squared sub graphs
where we can make that cut right up at
the top because if there are no sight
we're now dealing with cases where there
are no cycles so if there are no cycles
at most we could have a tree with the N
minus 1
CAES or sorry ed minus one edges so the
rest of the edges are not present so we
can make those cuts but in the cases
where we do have edges in the graph we
now can't make the cut up at the top of
the sub graph and we have to make the
cut down below and that kind of larger
part of the sub graph and there we might
have to cut up to N squared edges
because that's kind of the number of
edges that you need to cut in an
arbitrary graph to show that two
vertices are not connected and so we
have at most n of those sub graphs where
we have to make this N squared size cut
so the dominant factor is the slower
bullet point which gives us a cut of
size and cubed okay so we just multiply
these two things together and we get
that the query complexity is and to the
three-halves which turns out to be
optimal and also gives us a logarithmic
improvement over a previous best quantum
algorithm and is also considerably
simpler than the previous algorithm
which involved random doing picking
graphs at random and having some kind of
grabber search over all these random
graphs this is just a very clean
reduction tastic connectivity but kind
of amazingly just like the simplest
thing that you might think of is the
optimal thing which i think is nice
maybe it tells us that this is a good
approach yes that's a good question I
mean so it's always less than the
shortest length path and the cut is
always less than the smallest cut so
that those are normally pretty easy to
upper bound but if it has some complex
structure and it turns out also you can
add weights to edges so it's not only
figuring out what the best what the
smallest or what the maximum effective
resistance is but like calculating what
weights would give you kind of the
optimal so I think that especially once
you throw in the weights I think it
would be very challenging
not actually
not exactly sure that's true well but in
to know how fast those would run I think
you need to know what the effective is
like yeah you need to have a you know an
idea of the worst-case effective
resistance in any case I guess I want to
go back to what happens when we have
more than one cycle so if you have more
than one cycle that maximum effective
resistance decreases because you have
more paths and actually it turns out
that the effective resistance is always
exactly equal to the inverse of the
circuit rank so the circle rank is the
minimum number of edges that you need to
cut before there are no more cycles in
the graph and again this is kind of
beautiful we just like came up with the
simplest thing that we could think of
for evaluating SD connectivity and out
of it popped out of this effective
resistance popped this key topological
parameter that characterizes the number
of cycles so you know again it points to
maybe this is the right way to approach
certain types of problems so what this
also tells us is that if we're promised
that either there are no cycles or if
there are cycles there are many cycles
then the algorithm runs faster and it
scales like the inverse square root of
the number of cycles in the graph
another thing that was nice about this
was that this resumed result was proved
by second-year undergrads one of whom
didn't know anything about quantum
mechanics so I mean I think when you
that's kind of the the nice thing about
thinking about these primitives is it
really makes quantum algorithm design a
lot more accessible to people who don't
have a quantum computing background or
quantum mechanics background so right as
was just said there is a quantum
algorithm to estimate effective
resistance and effective capacitance of
the graph but so what this does it is it
actually gives us another kind of
interesting approach to algorithm design
because if you can create an ST
connectivity problem whose effective
resistance encodes some quantity that
you're interested in then
this algorithm gives you a way to
estimate that quantity so like in
particular for our example this just
immediately gives us an algorithm to
estimate the circuit rank of a graph so
again kind of a nice bonus of converting
to these SD connectivity problems okay
I'm almost out of time at it I don't
know if people like her diet you know
maybe people are very frustrated with
just having this black box and you're
wondering what's inside the blocks and
it's you know it's a span program
algorithm and there's a little bit of
information about it okay but the point
is we don't have to open up the black
box you don't need to worry about it so
I'll just end with a couple of open
questions and current directions
so this question of how to choose edge
weights so it turns out for some for
some of these optimal reductions to SD
connectivity you only get an optimal
reduction when you choose those edge
weights very carefully so figuring out a
good way to choose edge weights which
corresponds to like putting on resistors
of different resistance on the different
edges it's not clear how to choose those
I just from that slide at the beginning
we saw that a lot of these reductions
give you optimal algorithms but are
there certain conditions that we would
expect okay this type of problem will we
should get something pretty good from SD
conductivity this type of problem maybe
we want if we had a better way of
understanding the classical time or
query complexity for evaluating SD
connectivity that would immediately give
us a way to just generate separations
between quantum and classical algorithms
so there with the algorithm that Stacy
and Co she have for estimating effective
resistance it has kind of a nasty
scaling with the error so it'd be nice
to improve that I think that's possible
and then also I would just encourage all
of us to think about this idea of
primitives and how it can kind of
further the field by widening the field
by bringing more people into algorithm
design either through pedagogy or just
through talking to our non quantum
friends
[Applause]
so yes if someone gives you a graph
how are you constructing like a optimal
skeleton graph like riding the road yeah
so that deals with that conversion from
query to time complexity so as part of
the actual running of the algorithm you
have to implement a quantum basically a
quantum walk on the graph so you need to
have some way of basically turning that
skeleton graph into a quantum walk so
you know if you're at one vertex you
know which vertices you're allowed to
hop to so that's how you actually kind
of encode it into the quantum algorithm
time complexity so for create complexity
we assume you know we're not having the
structure of the skeleton graph is just
given to us that's something that we
kind of pre process ahead of time so
ahead of time you pre process if we
figure out how to do this quantum walk
step so the thing that we're don't know
is that that's string that bit string
and so that's the thing that we're
querying yes so so let's see the
discovery guys complete oh yeah so we're
in the adjacent it's kind of like the
adjacency matrix model so you could
imagine that every in this case every
single bit string has a unique edge or
sorry every bit in the bit string has an
edge that it corresponds to and for the
complete graph that the time you know
because walking on the complete graph is
kind of simple you just go to all your
neighbors so in that case the time
complexity is you know the query
complexity and the time complexity are
the same
you'll miss this but let's just say I
want to evaluate the size as boolean
formula unbalanced case what would the
query complexity be using this SD
connectivity framework you see the log
in like the length of the path if you
use this estimating the effective
resistance because the effective
resistance is always larger than the
shortest path it gives you some
information but I think there also is
when you when you actually measure you
can get information about one edge on a
path so then that can potentially be
leveraged into finding the path say so
you can find I think what you can do is
you can find one edge on one path every
time you'd run it so then you could kind
of go from there I think Ashley
Montanaro has some work on on doing that
[Applause]